This car has been abandoned in the middle of Paris for months or even years.
What I notice this about and especially why it's abandoned and not impounded.
In your opinion More than that it has no license plate on the front,
we'll go see the license plate on the back.
But do you already have an idea of why it doesn't move from
here and why it wasn't damaged by the impound lot.
Knowing that if you park in the street,
for example,
it will not be a cab in my opinion,
it will not be long.
You see compared to the 2 in the back,
look at all the foam around the car,
it proves that the car has not moved for a very long time despite the bad weather
The foam everywhere that forms on the car Look at the joints,
there is foam,
the tires are starting to deflate,
even look at it,
it looks like there is rust.
There is also 1 sticker for gasoline in Switzerland
which dates from two thousand fourteen.
That's why the car is untouchable in Paris because it is on a diplomatic
plate and 1 car on a diplomatic plate,
it has in quotation marks all the rights,
it can not pay the fleet,
it can park a little on the fly in the delivery places.
It doesn't matter.
It is not the 1st time that I see in Paris 1 abandoned diplomatic car,
I have already filmed on my account.